there's no question the latest virtual
reality technology is awe-inspiring but
this has been a week in which big Tech
has continued in failing to inspire its
users and investors I think it's
nonsense I think it was created to
distract us from Mark Zuckerberg's
inability to have a second good idea uh
and he he and so he's just uh trying to
conjure something into existence
industry insiders were most troubled by
the situation at Twitter
I do think it's pretty stunning how fast
these things can unravel and that's one
of the things that that I think that
this Twitter situation shows this week
a situation created almost entirely by
its new boss it will not be helpful for
restoring trust if you have uh Elon
making decisions where people wonder is
this being driven mainly because of
elon's personal preferences as Mr musk
asked Twitter users to vote on Donald
Trump's return to the platform a
revelation from Facebook's former lawyer
that it was having to manage attempts at
political interference a decade before
it came to public attention we saw the
the initial aspects of misinformation
campaigns sort of being built around
elections as early as 2000 and
2016 in 2008 um we had actually done a
number of projects to try to increase
Civic engagement on the platform so big
Tech is dealing with some pretty big
problems right now but looking around us
it's clear that there's a lot to be
optimistic about when it comes to the
Science and Technology that's going to
shape our futures from 3D printed organs
and alternatives to meat to the
artificial intelligence and Robotics
that they've done right will improve all
our lives
it's health challenges it's
environmental challenges food security
challenges and those problems are
experienced by the people who are not
where the Innovation is happening so I
guess our answer to that was we think
the future belongs to the people with
the problems to solve so that they can
drive the solving of those problems
so in answer to the question everyone
came here to address who owns the future
perhaps it's not scientists and
Engineers or the billionaires of Silicon
Valley but the rest of us Tom Clark Sky
News